hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
recently Sony has given us all the
Uncharted games on PlayStation Plus so I
thought this is the perfect opportunity
to look at Easter eggs in the series
starting with the sublime uncharted for
a thief's end whether this is your first
time experiencing the globe-trotting
finale of the Uncharted series or you're
a grizzled veteran let's look at 21 of
the best secrets and references we can
find Oh many of these will net you
trophies so there's every reason to try
these for yourself let's kick things off
with the developers themselves shall we
if there's one thing we can learn from
uncharted 4 Easter eggs is that Naughty
Dog aren't afraid to show themselves
some love can you really blame them
they've made some of the most important
PlayStation titles of all time on Nate's
travels you can find three separate
pieces of treasure that at first glance
all seem a little strange for an
uncharted game well that's because each
of them referenced to something in
Naughty Dog's Arsenal the first one
found in Chapter nine is simply called
strange pendant take a closer look at it
though and you'll notice that it's
actually the logo of the fireflies the
revolutionary group from The Last of Us
and if you turn it over the back you'll
see the name directly which is actually
a mash-up of the names of the two
directors of the Last of Us Bruce
Straley and Neil druckmann later in
Chapter 12 you can travel off the beaten
path to find this strange relic which
again on closer inspection is actually a
precursor orb from jak and daxter do you
remember those games happy days finally
all the way over in chapter 21 you can
grab onto this particularly precarious
ledge above Avery's ship to find the
final piece in this trilogy of strange
treasures the strange fruit can you
guess what it is of course you can it's
a piece of the iconic Whomper fruit from
the crash bandicoot series complete with
a cool pixelated look these are the most
in your face references from Naughty Dog
in uncharted 4 but you'll actually find
far more references to their games if
you look a little deeper in fact all
three of these franchises have way more
to offer in this game let's find them
The Last of Us is the wand which is
featured the most prominently over in
Chapter 12 gopher died near the sunken
ship and you'll find a skeleton with
some peculiar fungus growing out of its
face
this is a pretty clear reference to the
last of us and the infamous clickers the
infected creatures that scared the crap
out of us and probably killed you many
times or just me I died a lot in that
game how about something a little less
gross well this is quite spoilery
because it's in the epilogue of the game
so this is your chance now to run away
before I end this sentence have they
gone
they've gone okay in the game's epilogue
when you take control of Nate's daughter
Cassie you'll get the chance to explore
her room take a closer look at some of
those posters she has pinned up and
you'll see one for The Last of Us
American daughter's a comic book made by
Dark Horse sadly seems this asset was
made just for uncharted 4 and American
daughters doesn't exist well not yet
because I'm writing this before the Last
of Us part two comes out but Dark Horse
did publish a series of comics called
The Last of Us American Dreams which
serves as a prequel to the main game so
this makes them a little more real than
the other comic book think posters that
Cassie has around here such as savage
starlight - which you may recognize as
one of the comics Ellie read in The Last
of Us only for it to leave her in an
agonizing cliffhanger to be continued
well it looks like he got a sequel
I wonder if Ellie will get around to
reading it in the last of his part to
the other last of his references are
actually way more subtle than this and
super easy to miss later on in the game
when Nate and Elena are adventuring as a
duo
Elena briefly brings up one of her
previous jobs
Elena reveals she worked at a restaurant
called macho nacho this sounds like the
first job you have the producer on your
TV show no my manager from macho nacho
you worked at a macho nacho then in a
later flashback scene a young Nate can
find a medicine bottle that's from
Western pharmacy believe it or not both
of these companies actually exist in the
world of The Last of Us Ellie can easily
find stars for both of them in the games
Left Behind DLC so do The Last of Us and
Uncharted take place in the same
universe it's a stretch I know but I'm
on board with this I think they are the
same timeline
uncharted 4 other jak & daxter reference
is another blinkin you're missing moment
in the first chapter you'll find a
cupboard full of board games some of the
references here are more obvious than
others there's one call
democracy which you would usually call
monopoly but tucked away just below it
you can see the jak and Daxter boardgame
weirdly enough a jak and daxter board
game also appears in the Last of Us
which again suggests this is all one big
same timeline universe thing but then
there's also an uncharted board game in
The Last of Us
so maybe I'm thinking too far into this
okay I'll stop let's move on as for the
remaining Crash Bandicoot reference well
that one's a little bit more
in-your-face and I know if I didn't put
this in the video people would be up in
arms it's not really an easter egg it's
a slap in the face shout out to Crash
Bandicoot during chapter four after Nate
has spent a few minutes wandering around
his attic and admiring his handiwork
from the previous Uncharted games he
heads downstairs to find Elena firing up
a ps1 or as Nate puts it a TV game thing
I don't need to know what it's called
I've seen you play it's jumping and
running and I have a natural talent for
that this is just nostalgia it's
beautiful the attention to detail is
ridiculous just listen to this sound oh
it still gives me goosebumps to this day
it's not just an awesome tribute to a
classic video game it's also testimony
to just how far video games have come
even if some of them still involve
running straight towards the camera and
avoiding obstacles well now we've got
Naughty Dog's all the titles out of the
way you'd think that would be the end of
this self referential cycle were in well
no not a chance
it seems fitting though given uncharted
4 slightly more nostalgic take on Nate's
adventures such as an entire scene
dedicated to looking back at his career
in the Attic some really good memories
there but on top of that even some of
Nate's jokes make reoccurring
appearances in uncharted 4 if you choose
to take a dip during chapter 12 Nate
will try and play the classic game Marco
Polo with Sam Marco this may seem like a
nothing moment well he's actually done
this in every game since uncharted 2
back then he tried it with Chloe and had
pretty much the same amount of success
back then hey check it out Marco
really
in uncharted 3 he did this again all by
himself anyway let's move on from
Naughty Dog's ego and take a look at
other Easter eggs and references in
chapter 11
wander over to the passport bureau and
you can hear Sully and Drake have this
little exchange could be worse it could
be our stowed sky arstotzka is actually
the fictional country that plays host to
the 2013 indie classics papers please
where you play as an immigration officer
reviewing immigrants as they try to
enter the country
looks like naughty dog have some love
for the little guy too and also while
we're here this location is home to one
of my favorite Easter Egg conversations
in the game grab an apple on the way to
the market and make sure Nate stops to
meet this friendly little lemur shortly
after that pesky little guy will come
running up to you and steal that Apple
from your grasp earning you the trophy
don't feed the animals
well that's pretty cool as it is the
amazing part happens immediately after
just listen to this you know what after
this is over done with I'm gonna get a
dog come out of this and one be stopped
by you
can i name it Victor fast-forward to the
epilogue and as you can see the drakes
now have a family dog and its name is
vicky oh I suppose Victor wouldn't mind
too much it's close enough later on in
the same chapter Nate will find himself
making his way up to a clock tower keep
climbing your way to the very top of the
tower and eventually you'll see this
spire allowing Nate to take stock of his
surroundings not only will you net
yourself the trophy I can see my house
from here
but you'll also get a subtle reference
to the Assassin's Creed series where
each iteration of the game forces us to
climb up more randomly huge buildings in
order to synchronize and fully see our
surroundings whilst we don't know if
Naughty Dog themselves intended this to
be an easter egg
it was certainly interpreted that way by
Ubisoft when they later went on to make
Assassin's Creed origins they too had a
trophy for reaching the greatest high
point in the game and what was that
trophy called I can see my house from
here awesome stuff whilst we are here on
chapter 11 the next video game Easter
Egg is right around the corner when you
descend underneath the clock tower
you'll be faced with a puzzle revolving
around a series of pirates that all
existed in real life well almost all of
them there's one pirate featured in this
room that isn't named in the game and
neither Nate nor Sallee can recognize
him this is none other than Guybrush
Threepwood protagonist of the iconic
Monkey Island series not only does the
painting have a clear resemblance to the
character but you later find him pop up
again with an even clearer hint to his
name and there's loads more cool stuff
here in Chapter 11 when Nate and Sulley
finally leave the clock tower you'll see
a cutscene of the two trying to spot
Sam's tower when the cutscene ends do
yourself a favor and do nothing at all
seriously don't even touch the
controller stand still long enough and
you'll eventually unlock the stagefright
trophy in case this makes no sense to
you the reference is from the infamous
Uncharted 4 demo at e3 in 2015 when
exactly this happened
Nate was left standing there awkwardly
and the team had to restart the demo to
get it working awkward as hell but also
how cool is it that they can make fun of
themselves I respect that here's
something else to keep an eye out for
when you jump in a truck later in the
chapter if you take a closer look at the
license plate you'll see it reads VN 373
turn
upside down and look what you've got
Elena the name of Nate's wife cool touch
anyway how about something slightly
different to wrap this video up
throughout Nate's journey Naughty Dog
also managed to slip in a number of
other cultural references anyone who's
been online in the multiplayer portion
of Uncharted 4 will have noticed these
right away there are references to shows
like Breaking Bad in the form of Sully
scientists get up and even a few
pop-culture references to like Drake
doing that annoying hotline bling dance
I don't miss that in the slightest
however the clear winner amongst all
these references are a few nods to
uncharted z-- biggest inspiration
Indiana Jones while salmon Nate are
searching for gravestones in Scotland no
less Nate says this when he inspects an
incorrect date bad dates it's a
reference to Raiders of the Lost Ark
after indeed narrowly avoids eating some
poisoned dates himself birth dates oh
and also Nate can't help himself but use
one of Indies most famous lines when
fighting Nadine but you know all the
artifacts here are stolen they belong in
a museum honor amongst thieves I guess
so that's about it for uncharted 4
Easter eggs I feel like we should have
made this in 2016 but this was damn fun
to do in 2020 I do hope you enjoyed this
if you ever play this game again
remember you can jump into the bonus
menu after you've finished the game and
you can look at different ways to render
out the game's visuals switch it up
there's even one which is cel-shaded
which looks like Borderlands there's
another one where all the enemies are
bright red like super hot anyway I'll
keep talking if I don't shut up very
soon so I'll get out your way it's been
a pleasure I hope you enjoyed this I'm
Adam from PlayStation granade do the
like thing do the SUBSCRIBE thing and
I'll see you next time